What kind of international cooperation
can we expect in this situation,
given
such a hysterical antagonistic
position of the entire collective West
towards our country. It
’s not clear, of course, we still have
to survey these areas
and understand
what is there, what is down there, what is there at the bottom, in
order to understand the extent of the disaster
, there are definitely sides or  the side
that,
in the absence of the functioning of
these gas pipelines, gets the
opportunity to sell more of
its liquefied gas at
a higher price this is the first
side is well known The United
States of America there are also countries that
have the
military-technological capabilities
to carry out such sabotage
, these countries are also well known to all specialists
countries that
are not at all interested in
this are European countries that are deprived of
any backup route for the
supply of gas, which is so necessary for the
economy,
there are countries that sell this gas, which are
losing  there is no possibility to sell
significant volumes of gas such as
Russia,
so here everything is absolutely let's say so,
but here is a list of absolutely absolutely
such transparent and
understandable circumstances